الرئيس الامريكي اذا الان يتحدث عن توجيه
هذه الضربات الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
يقول بتوجيه مني ضربت القوات الامريكيه
اهدافا داخل منشات في العراق وسوريا
المنشات المستهدفه في العراق وسوريا
يستخدمها الحرس الثوري الايراني ومليشيات
التابعه له لمهاجمه قواتنا وجد وقفي هذا
هو التصريح الاول اذا من الاداره
الامريكيه الرئيس الامريكي بالفعل يحدد
ويقول بتوجيه مني هذه الضرب يحدد المناطق
المستهدفه هل من تفصيل اذا في تصريحات
الرئيس الامريكي حول هذه الموجه من
[موسيقى]
الضربات نعم محمد وردنا قبل قليل حقيقه
هذا البيان من الرئيس الامريكي كما كان
متوقعا حيث
ان كما قلت وردنا قبل قليل هذا البيان من
الرئيس الامريكي كما كان متوقعا كنت ارسل
هذه العواجل للتو حقيقه في هذا البيان
ايضا يقول الرئيس الامريكي على كل من
يسعون الى الحاق الاذ بنا فعليهم ان
يعرفوا هذا وهنا وهو اذا
اذيتمونا
الهجوم على القوات الامريكيه ليس كسائر
الهجمات السابقه هذا ادى الى مقتل جنود
امريكيين وهو شارك اليوم باستلام جثامينهم
في قاعده دوفر العسكريه
وتزامن هذا الرد الذي قرر الرئيس الامريكي
وقته
وكيفيه بدئه مع وصول جثامين الجنود
الامريكيين الثلاثه طبعا الرئيس الامريكي
في بيانه اكد بان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى الى صراع في الشرق الاوسط ولا الى اي
مكان في العالم وكان البيت الابيض حقيقه
قد اكد اكثر من مره بان الاداره الامريكيه
لا تسعى ايضا الى صراع مع ايران هذه
الضربات تاتي بعد ان استشار الرئيس
الامريكي كبار المسؤولين في مجلس الامن
القومي بحيث انه كانت هناك مخاوف من
احتمال ان تؤثر او يؤثر الرد الامريكي على
مساعي اطلاق سراح المحتجزين في غزه او
عمليات او جهود تبادل الاسرى وبالتالي هذه
المخاوف تبددت بعد
ان اكد المسؤولون في اكثر من مناسبه وحتى
في اجاباتهم على اسئلتنا هنا في البيت
الابيض بان تلك الجهود لن
تتاثر بهذا الرد الامريكي الذي بدانا نراه
اليوم محمد من خلال يعني المعلومات
المتوفره وجد ق معك ومن خلال صيغه هذه
واللهجه التي يتحدث فيها الرئيس الامريكي
يعني ما هو المختلف هذه المره في طبيعه
الضربات في طبيعه الرد بالنظر الى
الاختلاف ايضا في استهداف القوات
الامريكيه ومقتل الجنود و ان كان معلوما
الى اي مدى ستستمر
الضربات هو قال سوف تستمر خلال الايام
القادمه بالشكل وبزمان الذي يقرره واضح
بان هي ليست عمليه بدات اليوم وتنتهي ليست
غارات بدات اليوم وتنتهي المسؤولون هنا في
البيت الابيض يؤكدون بان هذه الضربات سوف
تكون في على الاراضي السوريه والاراضي
العراقيه لكنها لن تطال ايران مع تاكيدات
هؤلاء المسؤولين على ان الجماعات الموجوده
في سوريا
والعراق تاخذ اسلحتها التي تهاجم فيها
القوات الامريكيه من ايران لكن الاداره
الامريكيه لن يكون ضمن ردها على الهجوم
الذي ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه من جنودها اي
ضربات داخل الاراضي
الايرانيه بيان الرئيس بايدن كما قلنا كتب
بلهجه فيها الكثير من الحسم وذلك طبعا امر
مفهوم ذلك ان هذه المره الاولى التي قتل
فيها جنود
امريكيون من منذ السابع من اكتوبر
رغم وجود او رغم شن هذه الجماعات العشرات
من الهجمات
161 هجوما الهجوم ال 161 هو الذي ادى الى
مقتل هؤلاء الجنود وبالتالي هو الذي تطلب
من الرئيس الامريكي التحرك للرد شكل الرد
كيف سيكون مختلفا حقيقه عن ال الرد على
الهجمات هجمات الحوثيين لا نعرف حتى الان
هذا يعتمد على طبيعه المواقع التي
تستهدفها القوات الامريكيه ومدى تاثيرها
على القيادات الموجوده للميليشيات على
الارض في في سوريا والعراق الردع مهم جدا
ردع تلك الميليشيات من احتمال القيام
بهجمات جديده قد تؤدي الى مقتل المزيد من
الجنون هذا امر حساس ومهم بالنسبه للاداره
الامريكيه وربما للرئيس بايدن شخصيا كونه
يخوض عاما انتخابيا